I've been telling you for some time that the
damage Donald Trump is doing in the U S is
going to outlast his presidency, and this
is true both in terms of the practical and
the ideological. So as an example, the way
in which Trump has coarsened political language
and what counts. His discourse is going to
outlast Donald Trump. That won't be fixed
when Trump leaves office. But a more practical
example is that things like the alliances
with other countries that Trump has ruined
will take longer to fix than Donald Trump's
tenure in office. It could take years after
Trump has gone to repair those alliances with
other countries, with international institutions
and working groups. David, from a traditional
conservative, I guess we'd call him, he was
a speechwriter for George W. Bush. He wrote
an article about exactly this in the Atlantic
called America after Trump, and he points
out a lot of the ways in which Trump's damaged
to America is going to last longer than his
presidency.
One example is even though Republicans before
Trump have won the electoral college without
winning the popular vote, Trump lost the popular
vote by the biggest margin in history while
still winning the electoral college in 2016
that's likely to happen again if Trump gets
reelected in 2020 and the more that that losing
margin is in the popular vote while still
winning the electorial from argues, we'll
call into question the legitimacy of our political
system. And I agree, and I've been talking
about the electoral college for a long time
and from goes on to say if Trump loses narrowly
in 2020 the 40% of the country that likes
him is likely to turn into organized violence,
which will be destructive to our country's
social fabric for a very long time. It may
be Trump will try to get the military involved
to keep him in office because he feels that
he was cheated.
Now the military is not going to do that,
but simply a president publicly pushing for
that would be disastrous for the country and
it would allow Trump to keep harming the United
States beyond November of 2020 now, if Trump
loses big, as David Frum says, the possibility
of Democrats fixing everything and quickly
is really slim. And we have to recognize that
there is going to be a lot to fix. And unfortunately
the reality is that this takes a long time,
even a much more left wing president than
we've ever had before. If it's Bernie, if
it's Warren, they're not going to be able
to do everything and fix everything in four
years. And this will potentially make people
even more disaffected with the political system
because they'll say, look, Trump was terrible,
but we got them out and we put in Bernie or
Warren and they barely fixed anything because
it's of course, much easier to break things
than it is to build them as we know.
And then there are things David Frum doesn't
talk about in his piece. I've talked about
the justice system, the judiciary, the damage
done by Donald Trump's Supreme court and lower
court justice and judge selections is already
disgusting and it will continue and it will
persist for a long time because those are
positions for life and they are going to outlast
Trump by a lot. The damage of the environmental
regulations that were rolled back or skipped
may never be undone and every day we fall
further and further behind where we could
be. We don't make progress, we don't deal
with the environmental issue. That's by design.
This is what they want, but it will damage
the country long beyond Donald Trump's presidency.
This is just a partial list, but the idea
is to really make clear that we do not fix
the problems merely by getting rid of Trump.
That's like one a the prerequisite to start
thinking about all of the things that will
need to be fixed. There are people on the
left who recognize it. There are people on
the right like David Frum who recognize it
and we all need to understand that that the,
the removal of Trump in 2020 is not the solution.
It's merely step one in starting to repair
things. Let me know what you think. I'm on
Twitter at D Pacman. Follow me there. We'll
take a quick break and be back right after
this,